sur le plan du bilan chiffré des
résultats obtenus en disant on ne peut
évidemment que se féliciter de
l'application de cette loi et
reconnaître la force des quotas ils ont
contribué à faire voler en éclats cette
inertie en matière de parité économique
qui prévalait dans les instances
dirigeantes des grandes entreprises
françaises avant 2011
la diversité de genres s'est aujourd'hui
imposé au sein des conseils
d'administration des entreprises du sbf
composée des 40 valeurs du cac 40 est de
80 valeurs parmi les 200 premières
capitalisations boursières françaises
en 2020 la part des femmes dans les
conseils d'administration s'élevait
ainsi à 46,2 % le quota de 40 % fixés
par la loi et qui devait être apte en
2017 a donc été dépassé
un bond en avant majeur puisque ce taux
n'était que de 8 5% en 2007 20,6 pour
cent en 2011 au moment de l'adoption de
la loi et de 38% en 2016 cinq ans après
le vote de la loi
la france se situe d'ailleurs au premier
rang européen et mondial en termes de
féminisation des conseils
d'administration loin devant l'italie la
suède la finlande ou l'allemagne par
exemple
c'est un fait les progrès les plus
importants en termes de diversité de
gens dans les conseils d'administration
des grandes entreprises cotées ont eu
lieu dans les pays qui ont su imposer
des quotas
la france reste l'un des rares et à
avoir adopté une telle législation
contraignante avec la norvège qui a pris
ce tournant dès 2003 l'italie en 2011 et
la californie en 2018
on constate également que les progrès
sont d'autant plus significatif que les
contraintes imposées sont assorties de
sanctions
la loi française avait ainsi prévu le
gel des jetons de présence ainsi que
l'invalidation de toutes nouvelles
normes
a sion si l'objectif n'était pas atteint
la norvège a été jusqu'à menacer de
dissolution les sociétés n'atteignant
pas les objectifs fixés pour aborder la
thématique des conditions de
l'application de la loi depuis 2011
je me tourne donc naturellement vers
laurence parisot qui était présidente du
medef au moment de l'adoption de la loi
qui elle aussi a eu une action
déterminante marie jo l'a rappelé je me
souviens d'ailleurs de l'université
d'été du medef à laquelle on m'avait
demandé d'intervenir aussi pour
présenter cette loi et je dois dire
vraiment j'ajouterai en conclusion que
vraiment dans le monde entier
l'impact est l'image de la france grâce
à cette loi ont été absolument majeur
quand part relative modestie je disais
dans des interventions aux états unis ou
ailleurs que cette loi avait aussi été
initié en norvège on ne répondait mais
vous savez la norvège
bon c'est un beau pays mais c'est pas
important mais quand la france fait
quelque chose là c'est extrêmement
important c'est reconnu essai suivi dans
et admirées dans le monde entier il ne
faut surtout pas réfléchi une demi
seconde à l'idée de la remettre en cause
cette fois je ne savais pas que certains
cdd rouge et or en se disant que
finalement l'objectif est atteint
on n'a plus besoin de la loi bien sûr
que nous tous les retours en arrière
sont toujours possibles
donc c'est le toit elle est fondamentale
cette loi est une réussite et cette loi
doit être conservé
j'ajouterai que c'est très vrai ce que
vous avez dit madame le rapporteur sur
la réputation qu'elle a donné à notre
pays et en allemagne
au même moment peut-être qu'en gala
merkel s'était posé des questions mais
elle n'aurait jamais pu conduire un
texte de loi ou faire approuver un texte
de loin de cette nature car elle aurait
été face je peux en témoigner
un blocage absolu du patronat allemand
et au fouet
si ou récemment l'allemagne vient
d'annoncer des mesures tout à fait
importante allant dans cette direction
elle a dix ans de retard sur ce sujet
l'allemagne pour notre réputation
y compris en outre atlantique ça a été
une contribution extrêmement positive et
est tout à fait à des centres maintenant
je voudrais ajouter autre chose qui est
mon témoignage si le dire ainsi plutôt
l'observation de sa mise en oeuvre
pratique parce que j'avais la chance
d'être dans les conseils
d'administration déjà à l'époque j'ai
été au cours de ces dix dernières années
je voudrais que vous sachiez tous et
tout ceux qui n'ont pas eu l'occasion de
fréquenter les conseils mais les
conseils ont changé mais ccc même à
peine croyable difficile à décrire
je donnerai quelques caractéristiques de
ces changements
la première caractéristique est une
caractéristique de style c'est comme si
une légèreté nouvelle était introduite
dans les conseils sans pour autant
perdre le sérieux des conseils il y as
avec cette mixité immédiatement un ton
différent un temps plus constructif un
ton apaisé et
qui s'autorise une certaine créativité
ça c'est la première chose il ya une
deuxième dimension encore plus
importante pour la vie la conduite de
l'entreprise
c'est que les femmes le fait qu'elles
soient en nombre dans un conseil
ça joue aussi les femmes apportent une
un ancrage dans la réalité qui donne une
force supplémentaire au conseil
d'administration
car cet ancrage fait que la femme
administratrice cherche toujours à être
au plus près du réel au plus près du
vrai et du coup je l' ai vu plusieurs
fois
elles montrent un courage dans des
situations difficiles qu'on trouve pas
forcément dans un groupe de personnes
composé exclusivement d'hommes ça c'est
la deuxième dimension bien troisième
dimension qui alliez en fait que un
groupe geeks à conseil d'administration
mixte s'est introduit une forme de
modestie et sa hotte toute dérive de
toute-puissance cetc c'est l'effet de
même de grosses salles disparaissent si
je le disais d'une manière beaucoup plus
direct et ça c'est là où ici je crois
une dimension assez fondamentale quand
il s'agit pour les grandes entreprises
notamment de prendre des décisions
lourdes de conséquences
et puis il y a dernière caractéristique
que je voudrais souligner qu'ils aient
une capacité chez les femmes à faire le
lien entre l'intérêt d'entreprises à
l'intérêt général
d'ailleurs c'est un point vérifier je ne
sais pas si marie jo zimmermann qui a
quitté statistiques à celle ci mais ils
ne sont que ce sont en général plutôt
des femmes qui préside les comités rs
des grands groupes au sein des conseils
d'administration etc c'est pas
simplement parce que voilà ça arrange
tout le monde
ce soit une femme c'est parce qu'elles
savent mieux que beaucoup d'autres
prendre en main cette dimension de
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale tout en la rendant
compatible avec l'intérêt social propre
à l'entreprise
ces sensibilités sociétal bras long
c'est un plus qui est donnée à nos
entreprises et je voudrais dire je le
vois vraiment dans mon métier
aujourd'hui je suis président
une banque d'affaires alors
qu'aujourd'hui dans le monde de la
finance tout le monde travaille
intensivement sur question des critères
environnementaux sociétaux et de
gouvernance de ce point de vue là les
entreprises françaises ont sur
l'entreprise américaine ou anglaise ou
allemande des années les nuits en avance
d' avance et je n'exclus pas que cette
présence féminine dans les conseils
soient des facteurs qui expliquent cet
état avance française qui est reconnu
par les américains eux mêmes
je vais m'arrêter là parce que je
pourrais évidemment comme vous tout
perdre et d or sur ces sujets
mais je conclurai renouvellement
renouvelant pardon mais mes
remerciements à vous qui avez organisé
ce débat cette table ronde mais surtout
anne marie jo zimmermann
vraiment chapeau bas comme elle l'arabie
ce n'était pas du tout aussi évident que
ça vous pourrez être aujourd'hui c'est
une contribution majeure à la cause des
femmes qu'elle a apportée avec ce texte
est une contribution majeure à notre
pays
je pense que l'étape naturel prochaine
c'est évidemment évidemment des quotas
dans les comités exécutifs ou comité de
direction
pour moi ça ne fait pas l'ombre d'un
doute et je crois même l'avoir dit dans
mes dernières années à la tête du medef
et je dirais que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut probablement introduire dans
un outil législatif
même s'il ya déjà quelques
recommandations mais il est évident que
les quotas quand un effet bénéfique
c'est ce que je viens de dire et
deuxièmement en avance sur les grands
sujets qu à partir du moment où on peut
les mesurer et donc si on rentre dans
cette logique de la mesure de la part
des femmes dans les comités exécutifs et
bien il est évident qu'on fera des
progrès même si certains se sont fait
actuellement d'ailleurs je voudrais dire
que ce n'est pas rien si en france une
femme aujourd'hui directrice générale
d'un des plus grands groupes
énergétiques au monde je pense à
catherine mcgregor directrice générale
de j c'est tout à fait exceptionnel mais
encore plus symbolique je dirais
et historique et qui à mon avis illustre
parfaitement les progrès accomplis par
la france c'est le fait que dans
quelques semaines une femme barbara
dalibard d'être nommée présidente d'un
des plus grands groupes industriels ont
dès qu'il fait vraiment partie du
patrimoine économique français je pense
à michelin et regardez l'histoire de
michelin qui a toujours été une histoire
exclusivement masculine c'est vraiment
absolument hors normes et est
remarquable aujourd'hui michel
choisissent une femme comme présidente
merci de votre attention c'est
infiniment madame parquet sauf pour ces
témoignages je passe immédiatement la
parole à anne françoise mender maître de
conférences en sciences de gestion au
cnam qui va nous proposer aussi cet
éclairage international et nous
présenter les enjeux de l'application de
la loi ainsi que les leviers d'action
les plus efficaces en faveur de la
parité économique
la parole est à vous madame banda
bonjour je vous remercie pour cette
invitation donc moi j'enseigne la
gestion des ressources humaines ont
consterné devant des arts et métiers mes
recherches portent sur la gestion des
carrières la gestion de la diversité est
également les profils donc des femmes
dans les conseils d'administration
donc je voulais tout d'abord signalé que
les dames en cette soirée est assez
exceptionnel mais nous on est un petit
peu au milieu du gué enfin je voulais ce
n'est qu'il ya deux rapports excellents
qui ont été faits en 2019 de 200 pages
chacun environ sur l'application de la
loi sur les enjeux donc évidemment je
les reprendrai pas ici elles en avaient
connaissance on sait qu' il y avait les
bons chiffres dans les sociétés cotées
les grandes sociétés mais on sait aussi
qu'il ya beaucoup de progrès à faire au
niveau des sociétés non cotées
[Musique]
on est finalement un petit peu au début
quand même de l' aventure donc moi je
voulais simplement souligné trois
aspects revenir sur la dynamique
internationale et pas seulement
européenne montre est quand même dans
cette dynamique internationale la
persistance du plafond de verre
notamment dans les comités de direction
en deuxième moi je voulais rappeler les
quelques difficultés structurelles que
rencontrent les femmes dans cet univers
c'est un petit peu mon rôle ici les gens
pensent
et puis bien et moins revenir un peu sur
est ce qu'on peut faire
en france évidemment de mon ressort donc
sur la dynamique internationale et bien
sûr d'eric indiqué que c'était une
dynamique européenne
on a parlé de la norvège il y avait une
directive européenne qui était en cours
de réflexion et et c'est aussi une
dynamique mondiale initiée aux états
unis un bien sûr pendant par les world
ces discriminations dans les années 60
donc les entreprises américaines depuis
40 ans encourage devons encourager les
progressions de carrière des femmes ou
bien davantage fait les entreprises
françaises et européennes dès les années
80 puisque donc elles étaient soumises à
ces tournois c'est donc une
préoccupation anciennes et c'est sans
doute aussi l'ancien à michel 50 ans et
c'est aussi pour ça sans doute que les
entreprises de roubaix nous français
était déjà un petit peu inquiet
finalement même s'il ya eu des
résistances au fait que oui les femmes
et elle a été éduquée compétentes
elle avait des aspirations de carrière
est effectivement vous pouvez vous
continuer à se priver des talents de la
moitié finalement presque de la
population amitié donc c'est c'est un
enjeu de bonne gouvernance maintenant
donc depuis une vingtaine d'années les
places financières monde entier scrute
les politiques rh des entreprises et
sont attentifs au fait que comme les
entreprises cotées savons reconnaître
les talents féminins dans leur équipe
donc c'est le contexte
le mondial et ça s'est étendu aussi à
d'autres pays néanmoins malgré ce
contexte on a une progression des femmes
dans les postes d'encadrement au niveau
mondial en particulier aux états unis
on n est d'environ 30% ça dépend des
secteurs mais par contre on a toujours
ce plein air qui semble être une espèce
de loi d'airain autour des 11 à 18 %
selon les tailles et des entreprises
selon les secteurs et également sous
plafond de 20 % dans les conseils
d'administration des envies des pays qui
n'ont pas légiféré
donc c'est bien l'enjeu maintenant c'est
finalement l'accès à ces positions de
direction et en cela la loi comme
quasiment même bien sûr et loire tout à
fait alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est
toujours assez difficile de percer ce
plafond de verre malgré les compétences
les qualifications leur inspiration de
carrière c'est un peu deux processus
économie toujours davantage de femmes
dans les postes de direction et les
femmes aussi elle même bien souvent sont
réticents parfois postuler danser dans
ces postes on jouera en l1 ce qui est
dans les bras morts
c'est toujours difficile parce que les
réseaux sont toujours essentiellement
masculin notamment dans les entreprises
des secteurs à prédominance masculine et
donc aider les hommes à des phénomènes
naturels tout au long d'une carrière
continue de ce côté des infinité de
l'entrée
du mentorat donc il faut dit il faut des
politiques affirmées rech qui inclut
d'ériger des jeunes femmes ou des femmes
dont les leviers de potentiel sinon la
rouvre d'une chambre sociale finalement
continue de fonctionner les mêmes assez
naturel et c'est un petit peu un cercle
vicieux parce que ça entretient des
cultures justement et la liste pourrait
on dire en face à des demandes et des
secteurs mais dans lesquels les femmes
devant pas naturel hors antenne se
projeter ou en tout cas avoir des
aspirations de carrière pour rejoindre
ces milieux donc ça c'est bien l'enjeu
est de diversifier vers les autres lois
et dangereuse lamy cité
et puis c'est également des
investissements très coûteux pour des
jeunes qui peut avoir des chances de
familles qui n'ont pas nécessairement le
temps d'aller faire du réseau créé du
réseau investir dans les dents hausse
pour augmenter leur capital social
donc bon le les rapports mentionnent
aussi toujours incertain entier parfois
de comportement les femmes étant le plus
récentes dans ces univers en minorité on
s'est cru ils demandent à leur
comportement elles sont souvent
davantage exposés incertaine crette quoi
certaines attentes
donc ce sont pas des univers toujours
aisé et sa demande effectivement les
certaines l'ugtg donc
donc voilà ça explique que se plaindre
on devait quand même assez difficile à
percer il ya aussi le pen que j'ai des
fans pour avoir des carrières mais
peut-être dans des secteurs moins
stratégiques plutôt un support et
l'accès aux postes d'encadrement
opérationnel stratégique encore parfois
assez difficile et enfin bon on connaît
bien sûr toujours les normes de
l'importance de présentéisme de
disponibilité que demandent encore
certains univers et ce n'est maintenant
quand même ville avec le travail mental
je continue d'exercer certaines femmes
donc tout ça c'est des choses bien connu
c'est juste pour rappeler que c'est pas
du tout évident que les jeunes femmes
une rose à l'avenir a baissé sauf que la
fronde est parce que ce sont des
difficultés industrielles qui est
contesté alors il ya des signaux
positifs en avons davantage de femmes
diplômés d'écoles d'ingénieurs et ça
c'était vraiment important parce que
c'est là justement à des positions
pleinement opérationnel on a également
davantage de femmes cadres dont beaucoup
de secteurs
il ya deux racontent des signaux
inquiétants c'est on a trait aux
différents dans le secteur informatique
et ça c'était effectivement les
médecines de la veine échelle mondiale
actuelle les métiers de l'avenir
il ya un gros enjeu au niveau des pgi
encourager fortement des filles dans ces
filières et encourager secteur les
secteurs des tec a au moment de recruter
pour voir davantage de femmes alors en
conclusion un petit peu ce que sur la
situation française
en tout cas en france vient de se passer
alors madame parisot long mano à mano
rallongé avant la loi on stagne toujours
à 6 sur 7 pourtant pourtant les choix
mais tu es là c'était déjà diplômés des
grandes écoles elles avaient déjà des
carrières elle était déjà directrice et
djing financière et cetera stratégique
directrice générale donc la loi à
débloquer cet accès mais je pense
surtout dans les grandes entreprises
cotées
alors nous parce que les entreprises
sont scrutés par les analystes justement
des notations extra-financières qui
viennent goûter les femmes et donc où
sont les femmes
alors nous on en a deux c'est bien et
sont l'or et on risque quand même de
plafonner à 20 %
parce qu'on va dire ma 2 c'est bien
voilà on amour sans onel dans les normes
internationales et il ya des clubs il ya
des anglo saxon qui ont fait le club des
30% en dix ans quand est ce qu'on va
rentrer en bourse en 2001 on est qu'il
faut ça que je dis qu'on est pas même
aventure au milieu du gué
dans les comités de direction on a quand
même semblerait qu'en france de loisirs
on est quand même passé de 7% en 2014 à
18%
ce qui n'aurait sans doute pas eu lieu
je tends la loi et sans les les agences
de notation extra financière que ce que
les bourses maintenance queen's cette
indication donc qu'on peut faire le con
peuvent faire les gouvernements va
certainement pas en lui et loi mais sans
doute peut-être légiférer sur la
question où je voudrais juste terminée
par l'exemple britannique
alors je le disais aussi dans les
rapports que les pays qui n'ont pas eu
de loi ont quand même progressé sur les
ans et d'administration mais ont
progressé sous la menace d'avoir une loi
c'est bien parce qu'elle est loi que les
pays qui n'ont pas de nouveau progressé
puisque on leur a dit si vous ne restez
pas au niveau des entreprises vous aurez
une loi donc les lois agissent aussi sur
les pays qui n'ont pas de de loi donc
bon les britanniques ont proposé une
chasse jeu mais très intéressante
le ministère des finances sous theresa
may a demandé aux entreprises de la city
de s'engager officiellement sur le
recrutement la promotions et l'avènement
des carrières aux postes de direction
des femmes
c'est une chose qui s'appelle et 330
entreprises sans fin de plus de 50
occasions signées c'est du clic et le
ministère des finances
j'ai dit à lui-même et ils sont
maintenant avoir été en 2019
dans le joli donc je crois que c'était
un exemple intéressant ce qui promet de
fait au niveau d'un gouvernement mais ça
ne s'applique la queue pour le secteur
donc je commence lure est juste sur le
fait que disent les rapports à 2019
c'est qu'en france il a probablement
beaucoup d'entreprises qui connaissent
mal les lois c'est toi ou les différents
et qu'il faudrait déjà sans doute
peut-être déjà communiquer davantage sur
les obligations des entreprises
les sanctions puisque le quota n'est pas
atteindre grand nombre d'entreprises et
peut-être aussi bien sûr toujours
continuer d'agir de manière systémique
est beaucoup plus forte sur l'éducation
la mixité des métiers les duels accéder
des femmes en position de l informatique
les égouts d'informer chercher j pour
changer ces images et ces métiers
changer aussi bien sûr il continue aussi
de changer un peu l'image du pouvoir les
images des femmes et des hommes dans les
médias et les productions culturelles
dans les pme ou cette loi ne s'applique
pas moins de 18 % des femmes sont
représentées
ce chiffre est à prendre avec précaution
car dans certains cas cela peut être
encore moins
il est impossible en tout cas
aujourd'hui de rendre compte d'un
chiffre précis aucune statistique ne le
permet vraiment c'est un premier constat
une première insuffisances et puis
deuxièmement c'est le point le plus
important peut-être mais quand il n'y a
pas de quotas la part des femmes reste
en-deça de 20% le cas des pme montre
bien la limite des pratiques
d'autorégulation il faut ainsi favoriser
la transformation des mécanismes
d'autorégulation dans le sens d'un
renforcement des objectifs de parité
étendre cette politique aux pme autre
point les femmes ne sont que 18,2 pour
cent dans les commerces et les codir au
sein du cac 40 en 2010 neuf très légère
amélioration si je puis dire car elles
n'étaient que 7 % il ya dix ans les
mentalités évoluent les choses changent
mais lentement le ruissellement tant
attendue ne s'est malheureusement pas
produit et ce fameux plafond de verre
est toujours infranchissable
alors quand il n'y a pas de quotas la
parité s'arrête aux portes du vrai
pouvoir le comité stratégie du conseil
là où se prennent les décisions pour
l'entreprise est encore très largement
composée d'hommes contrairement au
comité rse moins impactants est
majoritairement composée de femmes elles
ne sont que deux dont je vais les cités
il ya là
p dg de
des ramettes et de l'entreprise de 4,40
isabelle kocher qui est déjà dans le gie
depuis 2016
donc non à l'amérique elle a changé mais
c'était en tout cas
non non non non il n'y est plus oui mais
je veux dire c'étaient deux fans
entreprises qui sont arrivés à la suite
de ces deux premières en tout cas
emblématique oui mais elles nous rendent
pas les ou laurence parisot a précisé
qu'aujourd'hui il y en avait quand même
une autre
oui oui as a service' sa maison je pense
que dans le problème de nos problèmes
d'isabelle kocher a été a été assez
douloureux à vivre donc je pense que
rendre hommage mais aujourd'hui il y ait
pu malheureusement oui mais au cours
actuel
donc où j'en étais je sais plus donc
dans le rapport du hce un point mérite
une attention particulière c'est celle
du sexisme financiers les femmes voient
leurs demandes de crédit rejeté deux
fois plus souvent elles reçoivent deux
fois et demie moins de financement que
les hommes moi j'ai pu le constater
c'est juste une petite aparté mais en ce
moment il ya le vendée globe cette
course qui 0 tour du monde et on a eu
navigatrice dans les alpes-maritimes qui
s'appelle alex et avariés et que
j'essaye d'accompagner en tant qu'élu le
plus facilement possible et c'était un
vrai parcours du combattant pour elle de
pouvoir être recevoir dans ce milieu
comme dans beaucoup qui a un milieu
assez masculin et c'était vraiment le
parcours du combattant que j'ai voilà
dont j'ai été le témoin et qui a
vraiment eu du mal à obtenir des
partenariats des partenaires et du
mécénat
un constat troublant place dans cette
situation compliquée les femmes qui
souhaitent ou ont fondé aussi leur start
up en entreprise ça c'est vraiment lors
des auditions au centre sept comités pas
peut-être commission de la parité
c'est vraiment ce qu'on a pu constater
un frein supplémentaire dans un parcours
déjà semé d'embûches d'embûches
alors ici encore les chiffres sont
éloquents et l'on constate que le
sexisme financiers ne faiblit pas au fil
du temps malgré nos efforts alors le hce
propose aller plus loin et souhaite
premièrement le financement public de
l'innovation par bpi france soit
conditionnée au respect par les
entreprises ou par les fonds
d'investissement de règles paritaire
pics à hauteur de 30% de leurs instances
de gouvernance et de direction et
deuxièmement l'insertion d'une clause
alternative établissant à 30 % le
pourcentage de femmes devant être au
sein de l'entreprise détentrice de
capital on va pas revenir sur
l'efficacité de la politique des quotas
mais je pense important de rappeler et
de souligner l'une des préconisations
également mise en avant par le hce je
parle de l'importance de prendre le
problème en amont donc l'action de
l'étoile ont contribué à défaire ses
mythes pour que le parcours scolaire
universitaire et professionnelle de
chaque femme soit imprégnés des mêmes
rêves et ambitions que ceux des hommes
il faut valoriser en incitant plus
fortement les jeunes filles à investir
des secteurs composer aujourd'hui encore
majoritairement d'hommes tout passe par
l'éducation qui est le vecteur principal
est essentielle pour que le changement
de mentalité puisse se faire dans les
meilleures conditions et le plus
rapidement aussi et pour cela il faut
donner des outils aux jeunes filles afin
qu'elles osent sans crainte
encore moins si elles se tiennent à leur
sexe et surtout qu'elle comprenne qu'une
femme doit évoluer dans sa carrière en
étant soumise aux mêmes conditions que
les femmes anne françoise d'under disait
à en parler à l'instant justement de
l'importance de traiter le problème dès
le plus jeune âge et je pense aussi que
les politiques publiques doivent se
concentrer aussi dès le plus jeune âge à
hasnon pas former et sensibiliser les
nouvelles générations notamment par
exemple la mixité des métiers il faut
donc déconstruire les mentalités pour
rebâtir des objectifs donc pour conclure
mon intervention je voudrais citer
quelques unes qui à mon sens de
propositions qui s'inscrivent totalement
dans la pâte unité nos échanges sur les
évolutions de cette loi donc premier
objectif c'est de conforter la parité au
sein des conseils d'administration et de
surveillance
il faut maintenir l'objectif des 40 60 %
sont toutefois prôné une parité stricte
de 50% qui en raison d'obstacles
juridiques et techniques et
difficilement faisable et deuxième axe
de réflexion abordés l'extension
indispensable des objectifs de parité au
comex donc et au codir on l'a dit à
l'instant dernière mesure peut-être la
nécessité de conditionner l'obtention de
financement public de l'innovation à la
proportion de femmes représentées au
sein des instances de gouvernance et de
direction parmi les détentrices de
capital voilà à peu près les
propositions de du hce qui qui a essayé
de travailler sur le bilan de
l'évolution de cette loi et voilà et
nous en tant que et lui dans l'égalité
professionnelle économique
on s'évertue aussi à travailler sur sur
l'égalité dans le monde de la politique
vous tout vivait aussi et donc on il
semblerait qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de similitudes entre ces deux milieux
qui convient de continuer en tout cas à
travailler à faire évoluer en passant
malheureusement ou heureusement par la
loi vous savez sur le terrain de
l'entreprise g et ça fait presque trente
ans je suis son terrain de l'entreprise
plutôt dans les entreprises
internationales j'ai toujours travaillé
pour les entreprises internationales
american express ibm lenovo est en fait
depuis depuis toutes ces années je me
bats justement pour pour l'égalité et
pour l' équilibre en fait se dirait que
d'ailleurs on ne parle pas de parité
parce que on sait que dans ce secteur là
technologique et scientifique
en effet on part tellement avec une base
tels tellement faible que en effet on
parle de la mixité mais je voudrais
aussi saluer
l'impact de cette loi au delà des
chiffres et on paie très cher des
chiffres que vous l'avez tout dit mais
de ce que de l'impact de l'engouement le
terme a été utilisé de cette conviction
qu'en fait en effet on pouvait être
fiers de ces avancées et je me souviens
c'était d'ailleurs hommage forum il y à
peu près dix ans quand donc quand la loi
a été annoncé mais mes collègues
étrangère américaine et chinoise qui
n'en revenait pas et qui disait mais
comment vous allez faire ça avec une
petite pointe dont vie je dirais de
savoir qu'on ait fait cette loi est une
mise en place alors moi je pense
aujourd'hui aussi que en fait on est
aussi un moment charnière je pense que
le fait que cette célébration madame jay
berman de cette loi est une formidable
opportunité pour nous pour nous les
acteurs les actrices de la société
civile pour l'état pour tous les moyens
de pression pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse continuer justement à avancer on
a on a prouvé que les quotas que
l'obligation à nous ont données
gouvernementales et de l'état fait
avancer plus rapidement
ceci étant on pensait que la loi ce
n'est pas suffisant et en effet c'est
cette conjonction moi je parle toujours
d'un cercle vertueux qui va combiner
c'est une volonté politique forte qui
s'expriment évidemment à te faire à
travers la loi mais aussi un engagement
de la société ou une pression sociétale
et puis cet enjeu de performance
économique
heureusement aujourd'hui grâce justement
à toutes les études qui ont été faites
porté par le forum avec évidemment six
études de l'oscd de mckinsey je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui on ait pris trop obligé
dans les entreprises d'expliquer que la
mixité c'est un facteur de performance
économique c'est à dire que c'est
quelque chose qui est maintenant je
dirais à qui on est plus sur ce stade là
maintenant on est plus sur comment faire
en fait pour attirer les talents des
talents comme notamment dans les
secteurs où les femmes sont en minorité
et comment faire pour arriver justement
à cette mixité et après il faut il faut
attirer les fans mais après il faut les
faire monter et la difficulté de les
faire monter si on les fait un moment
il n'y a pas une obligation c'est qu'on
va toujours trouver même si vous avez un
dirigeant qui est tout à fait ses dires
est convaincue par la cause mais il y
aura toujours quelqu'un dans le middle
management qui ne va pas prendre la
bonne décision aura quelqu'un en
recrutement qui ne va pas recruter un
bonne personne
il n'y aura pas tous les moyens qui sont
mis en place et si kylie a justement ces
objectifs chiffrés et qui sont mesurées
et avec des sanctions qui sont contrôlés
peut le dire nous on va on va continuer
à travailler dans nos réseaux nous ça
fait 20 ans que en effet jeu j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir de participer à la
création du premier réseau l'un des
premiers réseaux d'entreprise chez ibm
en effet un peu là par l'afflux sans
l'inflation ce anglo saxon pour
aujourd'hui est dirigé par une femme
il ya une femme cio très emblématique
sony rometty et le comité paritaire se
met à exister paritaire alors je dis pas
que bon c'est attrayant encore beaucoup
de choses à faire mais je pense qu'il ya
des entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont
très engagés elle arrive à des résultats
mais c'est au bout de 20 ans 1 donc on
se dit que quand même on aimerait aller
un petit peu plus vide
on va d'ailleurs avec avec le sac tard
elle qui est un réseau de réseaux
d'entreprise dans une quinzaine grandes
entreprises d'un secteur technique et
scientifique française et étrangère on
va justement fêter nos façons le 4 mars
et alors il est vrai que quand on
regarde est quand même bon la coupe et
je dirais le verre est à moitié plein il
ya eu plein de choses extraordinaires
bon ceci étant on se rend compte encore
là les chiffres sont là que vraiment le
le plafond de verre et cet accès aux
postes de responsabilité on a en moyenne
20 % de cadres dirigeantes donc
évidemment c'est pas assez alors certes
on est sur une base de 30 % de femmes
alors c'est clair que c'est plus
compliqué d'avoir d'avoir d'avoir 50 %
de femmes dans ces dons sont ces sectes
mais se fasse ceci étant je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une impulsion forte
et ce qui est important est le thème
notre table auront cessé sur les réseaux
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
il ya pléthore de réseau et parce que je
voudrais dire pour les personnes qui
nous écoutent et surtout les jeunes
générations
prenez du temps pour aller aller dans
des réseaux c'est très important
pourquoi savez les réseaux trop
professionnel c'est assez récent les
femmes c'est vrai pour des tas de
raisons vous l'avez dit par manque de
temps par le fait aussi qu'elles ont
toutes le syndrome de la bonne élève
elle dit bah oui finalement si je
travaille bien mais se devait avant le
banc tos je veux sauver de décrocher de
bons potes on va reconnaître mais mes
talents non pas dans le passé dans la
tradition comme les hommes les hommes y
sont naturellement au réseau le sport
l'école
bon les femmes il faut un petit peu les
inciter leur montrer l'importance de ces
du temps professionnel cdu c'est le
temps libre qui est dégagé pour aller
dans un réseau c'est quelque chose qui
est important et il y assez bien cette
prise de conscience aujourd'hui et nous
je dirais les seniors on a vite
justement les jeunes femmes à aller dans
ces réseaux parce que ce sont des
véritables lieux de l'apprentissage
c'est des lieux qui permettent aux
jeunes femmes notamment dans des
entreprises de décrypter un peu les
codes de l'entreprise
c'est un lieu qui est un lieu de liberté
de parole hors hiérarchie est évidemment
les entreprises ont bien compris que
c'était aussi une plateforme très
innovante parce que qui est son sens
force de proposition et on voit
aujourd'hui il y à toute une série de
réseaux les réseaux internes des
entreprises les réseaux professionnels
et là en cette période de crise je dois
dire que c'est pour toutes celles qui
sont dans deir ezzor n'a passé d'autant
à vision conférence et c'est très
important parce que là c'est sait
réellement ce qu'on appelle la
solidarité la sororité et je pense que
si il faut faire très attention aux
pièges dans lesquels on nous enferme ses
stéréotypes en pensant que les femmes
justement sont compétitives les unes
envers les autres ça vraiment c'est
quelque chose il faut faire attention à
ça parce qu'il ya toujours le moment on
va dire oui de toute façon celle ci
allait d'un petit peu agressive et en
fait je crois que les des réseaux et la
multiplication des réseaux et la preuve
justement de cette sororité et de ce
de ce sentiment d'être unis en fait
ensemble
alors ces réseaux féminins ce sont des
réseaux si mixte à se dire je veux pas
oublier les hommes et des tensions il
yad'ailleurs mouvement on voit qu'il ya
énormément d'hommes aujourd'hui de plus
en plus qui soutiennent ces réseaux qui
se sont font partie prenante
parce qu'évidemment comme c'est quand
même eux qui ont le pouvoir dans la
majeure partie des cas c'est vraiment
important de les avoir avec nous et il
ya des tas d'hommes champions le co2
champions d'ailleurs hommage emmener
tout le temps mais mes dirigeants pour
qu'ils soient bien ceux d'hier est
imprégnée de l'importance de ce qu'il
devait faire et est un bon signe et
alors on puce est alors aujourd'hui ce
qui est intéressant dans les réseaux ces
convois sorte de rassemblement aussi de
collectif donc match depuis quatre ans
dans le sillage d'ailleurs de laurence
rossignol
quand elle avait le sl elle avait réuni
une quarantaine de réseaux de toutes
sortes à dire des réseaux qui s'occupe
de la lutte contre l'excision comme le
lien qui s'y tient sur l'égalité pro des
réseaux dans la culture pour travailler
autour du sexisme
il serait en fait c'est intéressant de
voir que quand on réunit toutes nos
forces de notre synergie toutes nos
énergies pour lutter quand même contre
le sexisme est là bon évidemment avec
avec tout ce qui a été fait notamment
part par brigitte grésy bien sûr pour
vraiment mettre l'accent sur le fait que
le seul le sexy c'est la pierre
angulaire qui légitiment tous les
inégalités nous dans les entreprises
pourquoi dans le secteur scientifique et
technologique
on n'arrive pas à recruter des femmes je
crois qu'il ya une étude sanders kahn
qui montrent que 40 % de femmes qui sont
diplômés de steve parts de cette filière
là c'est pas parce que le métier les
intéresse pas c'est parce qu'à un moment
donné le déséquilibre de jean est
tellement fort que quelles que soient
les formations des leurs peuples ont
fait contre le sexisme contre il est
bien conscient il y à cette prédominance
masculine de cette culture en fête qui
créent des stéréotypes et créent des
comportements dans dans lesquels l'autre
sexe qui est en minorité ne se sent pas
à l'aise et du coup c'est important
c'est pourquoi moi je suis engagé dans
ce collectif d'ailleurs gens qui va
organiser sa quatrième journée nationale
grosse ex'im de 25 janvier et on parlera
des violences économiques autre
collectif aussi important qui vient de
se créer c'est tout gap qui réunit une
quarantaine de réseau du secteur public
et privé et ça c'est aussi intéressant
je suis aujourd'hui au sénat je dois
vous dire que je suis très ému et honoré
d'être ici au céda et en travaillons
avec les femmes de la haute
administration je vois combien en effet
on a intérêt à travailler en ce sens
parce que finalement on est confronté au
même problème ce plafond de verre même
si c'est vrai dans le privé pour des tas
de raisons notamment des raisons
économiques de la pression aussi de la
productivité fait qu' il y a eu ce
besoin de mixité qui fait que les
entreprises ont pris ont été parfois en
avance sur seulement des politiques
d'égalité pour permettre d'attirer plus
en plus de femmes notamment dans les
secteurs où j'ai travaillé mais alors
aujourd'hui c'est vrai des réseaux en
fait il y a trois grands axes c'est à
tous qui développe les talents féminins
c'est à dire le dob bon père perte
personnelle tout tout ce qui est autour
de la visibilité se fait de façon
excellente et urbain fort en mettant en
visibilité les femmes leur potentiel
pour qu'on ne puisse pas dire en effet
non non il n'y en a pas et puis il ya il
ya un deuxième pont jeudi rizal qu'il
était très important
c'est tout ce qui favorise justement la
mixité la culture inclusive et là c'est
le maître mot gentil ccc l'accusion la
lutte contre les discriminations
évidemment on applaudit le congé
paternité mais on aimerait qu'il soit un
peu plus l'eau parce qu'il fait d'autre
on n'est pas mort enfin c'est très bien
c'est un c'est un premier pas et toutes
ces formations qui sont faites
aujourd'hui des formations sexisme savez
il y à il ya aujourd'hui des dans des
grandes entreprises je citerai edf par
exemple fait partie du charter l iliade
et d'éveil téléphonique d'éveil 2-2
contre les violences sexistes
ce qui est intéressant aujourd'hui c'est
que croyait il n'y a plus la barrière
finalement entre la vie professionnelle
et la vie privée est aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs dont lé travail dans
l'entreprise
elle est responsable finalement du
bien-être de ses employés dans
l'ensemble de son écosystème
et quand on parle de sexy c'est pas
simplement le sexy
dans la vie professionnelle c'est aussi
le sexy dans son ensemble et puis la
dernière chose c'est évidemment de
mesurer les progrès enfin ce sont les
réseaux qui sont un petit peu des outils
comme ça et des incitateurs et qui
cristallise et qui pousse qui pousse les
directions à ce qu'il y ait des
objectifs chiffrés alors évidemment
quand les objectifs chiffrés sont
imposés alors chaque entreprise va
donner ses objectifs mais quand se
dirait on a la chance il en fait pour
pour moi c'est une chance de pouvoir
qu'il y ait une loi qui puisse imposer
des objectifs chiffrés serre qui doivent
être réalistes parce qu'autrement il est
clair que on aura il y aura toujours des
moyens de ils sont axa ce réaliste de ça
sur mesure à des écarts en effet que ce
que ça soit contrôlée mais je pense que
aujourd'hui évidemment cette loi était
formidable au delà de ceux d'hier et des
chiffres et c'est ça qui est important
ça à sacrer une profonde révolution et
ça donnait confiance aussi ça a donné
confiance aux femmes dans ces
entreprises là et qui en effet sont
fiers de savoir que cette entreprise là
tant de femmes au conseil
d'administration
évidemment elle a créé des frustrations
parce que finalement en avance mais en
même temps on se dit qu'aujourd'hui
c'est je pense que l'état paie live
voici ouais j'ai beaucoup d'espoir je
partage avec toutes les femmes et les
hommes qui active qui sont dans
l'entreprise que en effet on est une loi
des quotas dans les comités exécutifs et
des propos de bruno le maire sans son
courage en vo elisabeth bost moreno
évidemment qui connaît bien le monde de
l'an de l'entreprise nous savons que
nous pouvons compter sur sur ce soutien
je pense que en effet bon il ya eu
seulement 7,7 fille de compétition avec
avec l'allemagne n'en retient finalement
l'allemagne mais bon ça on peut pas
comparer je suis entièrement d'accord
avec vous on a quand même dix ans
d'avancé sur l'allemagne et même en
terme de mentalité
mais je pense qu'on est à un moment clé
et donc
je voudrais vous dire que vous qui est
je dirais dans les instances de pouvoir
de l'état
vous pouvez compter sur les réseaux vous
pouvez compter sur les entreprises
vous pouvez compter sur les dirigeants
qui sont aujourd'hui les dirigeants et
les dirigeants ils sont convaincus de
l'importance de la mixité vont osciller
là ce serait avec mon expérience de
communicante c'est un enjeu de
réputation fondamental pour les
entreprises aujourd'hui je dirais si on
veut avoir les meilleurs talents
en fait les jeunes aujourd'hui
choisissent les entreprises en fonction
justement de leur réputation en fonction
de leur politique aussi par exemple
vis-à-vis du dupont j'efface veut même
le congé paternité
moi j'ai des jambes qui en effet ont
pris des congés paternité font partie il
y en a qui fait partie d'une dune
sociétés de la nouvelle économie qui en
effet il a une battante savez pour les
jeunes talents et je pense que c'est un
lait les entreprises ce sera peut-être
pas simple à organiser mais les
entreprises vont moi je vois en fonction
de ce que du travail quotidien avec
notamment l entreprise du satin terrell
peut-être parce qu'elles sont dans un
secteur où c'est tellement difficile de
faire venir des femmes elles seront
prêtes je dirais à avancer en sachant
que de toute façon c'est un objectif
sociétal et c'est un objectif de l'êta
et ça permettra surtout de mettre la
france comme tu disais championne du
monde
enfin je crois à l'infa l'important
c'est que les femmes et les hommes
aujourd'hui puissent bas puissent avoir
le même accès la même égalité des
chances et donc on vend des femmes en
effet au plus haut niveau et merci
encore madame gym amman pour tout ce que
vous avez fait pour nous merci martin
juste avant que tu prennes la parole je
voudrais
juste dire un petit mot parce que vous
parlez de mixité je pense que la mixité
aussi est importante dans toutes les
strates je donne juste deux minutes mon
expérience personnelle et répondant
devant monsieur therrien j'ai fait l'ifa
en 2015 et moi je te mets dans la
politique à 20 ans mais après je me suis
dit qu'il fallait impérativement je
puisse avoir une expérience dans le
monde économique parce que il est très
important que les politiques ne reste
pas dans leur monde et donc pendant huit
ans j'ai été dans plus grands groupes
d'édition européen et donc au comex et
c'est par ces termes l'intermédiaire que
du coup je me suis il faudrait que je me
perfectionne parce que je n'avais
absolument aucune notion en finance donc
et j'ai fait l'ifa est vraiment c'était
une expérience formidable
mais après je me suis heurté à une
immunisation total c'est à dire que les
cabinets de recrutement
je ne rentre dans aucune case je n'étais
pas étrangère je ne paierai pas trois
langues
je n'étais pas des amis que je qui sont
chers à véronique morali patricia
barbizet etc et donc soit on me disait
vous rentrez pas dans le moule et donc
on n'a rien pour vous alors je pense que
après 20 ans d'expérience politique dans
plein de domaines différents je pouvais
apporter au contraire des qualités
d'adaptation et de sensibilité aux
intuitions man 2 sera gratuit sion
politique et on a besoin de ça dans les
conseils d'administration la stratégie
ça se fait aussi par là ou alors en
effet ben je devais aller piquer la
place entre guillemets de celles qui ont
les cinq postes dont elles ont droit
puisque la loi limite à cinq postes de
conseil d'administration et dont je suis
en train d'en quelques réseaux et c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya pas de compétition entre
les femmes et c'est très bien mais il
faut aussi en effet que ces hommes qui
sont encore au pouvoir soit assurée
d'aller un peu au delà de ce qu'ils
connaissent déjà soit de cocktails et
les amis enfin ou d'où des jets et même
pire des épouses d'amis parce que du
coup on reste dans l'antre soit voilà
soit en effet de pouvoir permettre à
cette mixité aussi des talents dans le
monde dans le monde
voilà de l'entreprise on vient de
parcours très différents et je pense tu
as tout à fait raison qu'ils arrêtent de
dire que j'étais rapporteur sur la loi
programmation de la recherche et donc
notamment numériques et ans et en
informatique on manque cruellement de
femmes mais je pense aussi que c'est
bien de pouvoir en effet continuer à
avoir des gens qui viennent d'un autre
secteur que celui pour lequel vous allez
postuler et donc c'est vrai que je
voulais vous donner ce message à parce
que c'est une expérience du coup assez
humiliante en fait de dire voilà j'ai
géré pourtant bien réussi mon grand oral
à l'ifa et j'étais content mais en fait
voilà toutes les portes se sont
refermées
parce que je ne rentrais pas dans ce
moule françoise de panafieu et moi qui
avons fait mis fin comme comme
personnalité politique et donc voilà je
j'aurais bien aimé voilà mais c'était
une petite expérience le personnel mais
je veux dire que melor s'est pas trop
tard un jeu c'est bien moi je sais bien
mais j'aurais peut-être une deuxième vie
ou une troisième vie d'ailleurs parce
que bien évidemment j'ai l'intention
mais du coup voilà c est donc je moi
j'ai bien l'intention continuer à
travailler justement sur un texte sur
les comex et sur ces sujets là et même
aussi sur le code afep medef parce que
je pense qu'il ya des choses encore à
améliorer et peut-être que du coup mon
expérience à l'ifa au moins permis à ça
de me dire que il ya des choses encore
améliorée sur le plan législatif et que
du coup bah je suis impliqué d'autant
plus sedan dans ces sujets pardon
d'avoir parlé mais je voulais vous
donner cette expérience qui était la
plus malheureuse très très très rapide
merci d'avoir évoqué un point qui nous
avait beaucoup interpellé à l'époque
c'était les cumuls de mandats et jeu
pense qu'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il faut effectivement à la suite de ce
que je viens d'entendre il faut au moins
posé la question parce que alors
problème il va être très clair c'est que
bon j'en ai beaucoup discuté avec au
conseil à l'égalité et quand on fait les
statistiques on se rend compte que les
femmes comme eu énormément
donc est-ce que assis ici si je bats
écouter les chiffres sont là
malheureusement et gérait que bon moi
j'ai observé en 2011
on ne pouvait pas imposer un cumul parce
que c'était dans la proposition de loi
je vous cache pas et on l'a enlevé tout
simplement parce que nous même en tant
que politique
on ne s'était pas appliqué le cumul de
mandats aujourd'hui le pôle et au niveau
politique on l'a on a le cumul à demanda
et moi je pose aujourd'hui la question
officiellement jus très contente que
l'or est abordé ce sujet parce que ça me
taraude depuis un certain temps est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas aussi un
tournant pour se poser la question
éventuellement d'un cumul de trois
mandats pour les conseils d
administration voilà alors s'introduit
complètement en cause et c'est vous le
législateur a travaillé matt martin jeu
du coup je te laisse la parole je suis
désolé de cette incursion mais ça
introduit en effet tout à fait le fait
que l'on ya sûrement des évolutions pour
pour cette joie à cette loi de 2011 on
que marié je te laisse la parole et si
tu devais
rejoindre aussi l'hémicycle n'hésite pas
je resterai bien évidemment avec nos
invités jusqu'au bout c'est la moindre
des choses est de pardonner nous pour
ces bouleversements et mais c'est son c
et puis je trouve que c'est quand même
vraiment s'attableront j'y tenais aussi
particulièrement comme comme joëlle
hénot et mes collègues et donc on
prendra le temps encore qu'il faudra oui
merci madame la présidente moi je n'ai
pas de problème je n'ai pas prévu de
retourner dans l'hémicycle donc je serai
avec vous jusqu'au bout voilà je voulais
donc remercier les remercier les
différentes intervenantes qui se sont
exprimés et en particulier bien sûr
marie jo zimmermann et faire le constat
que toutes les interventions me semblent
converger à ce moment à savoir que la
loi de 2011 a vraiment permis des
avancées considérables en matière de
parité économique mais que la loi a
aussi ses limites
et donc si vous me le permettez faire
une courte synthèse pour poser justement
les limites que nous avons les unes et
les autres repérés
tout d'abord la loi de 2011 ne concerne
pas de la même manière toutes les
entreprises en effet les quotas imposés
par la loi de 2011 ne sont atteints que
dans les entreprises cotées du sbf 120
pour les plus petites capitalisations
les femmes étaient moins d'un tiers dans
les conseils d'administration 2018
les entreprises non cotées de 500
salariés plus et au moins 50 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires compte est
elle moins de 25% de femmes au sein de
leur conseil d'administration en 2019
enfin les entreprises de 250 salariés et
plus et 50 millions de chiffre
d'affaires concernés par les mêmes
quotas depuis le 1er janvier 2020 n'ont
pas encore atteint l'objectif de 40% de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration et de surveillance
deuxième constat la loi dite copé
zimmermann ne concerne que les conseils
d'administration et de surveillance
les véritables
danse décisionnaires ne sont donc pas
concernés par les contraintes qu'elle a
mise en place cela a été repéré dans les
différentes interventions les quotas
imposés n'ont ainsi pas encore aider les
femmes à pousser la porte des comité
exécutif comex ou des comités de
direction codir en france dans ces lieux
de pouvoirs qui nous sont soumis à
aucune contrainte légale les femmes
occupent moins de 20% des postes dans le
sbf 120
troisième constat enfin la question du
contrôle de l'application de la loi est
primordial
or c'est en partie là que le bât blesse
si le suivi de l'application de la loi
et transparent s'agissant des grandes
capitalisations boursières
il est plus aléatoire pour les autres
entreprises
pourtant aujourd'hui soumises aux mêmes
dispositifs contraignants
il semble que l'état manque d'outils et
surtout de moyens pour contrôler
l'application des dispositifs de parité
économique qu'il a lui même instauré
alors la question qui est devant nous
c'est de savoir quelles sont les
perspectives d'évolution aujourd'hui
faut-il modifier la loi
s'inspirer d'exemples étrangers
instaurer des chartes de bonnes
pratiques à mettre en oeuvre dans les
entreprises en matière d'accès des
femmes aux responsabilités économiques
s'en remettre à l'action des régulateurs
économique pour évoluer vers plus de
parité dans les responsabilités à tous
les niveaux alors je pense que vous
n'avez pas été sans noter que lundi le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire a
annoncé devant nos collègues de la ddfl
assemblée nationale être favorable à
l'instauration de nouveaux quotas dans
les entreprises pour faire progresser
l'égalité hommes femmes non seulement
l'égalité salariale
également l'égalité en matière de
gouvernance comme nous tout je crois il
a trouvé regrettable qu'une seule femme
dirige une entreprise du cac 40 et a
déploré que les comités de direction ne
compte aujourd'hui que 17 % de femmes
pour favoriser l'accession des femmes à
des postes de direction dans les
entreprises françaises
il s'est dit favorable à l'instauration
de quotas et a déclaré il faut
maintenant être capable de passer la
vitesse supérieure et donc de rentrer
dans une logique plus ambitieuse qui
passe par des quotas est donc j'allais
dire le l'ouvragé est maintenant sur le
métier a à nous de saisir la balle au
bond et de travailler dans le bon sens
pour faire que la loi puisse donc
progresser et pour ce faire nous nous
proposons de demander conseils avis
propositions pistes de travail à madame
françoise savez ce qui est présidente de
l'association des femmes
expert comptable et qui est engagée pour
permettre à davantage de femmes de
participer aux véritables lieux de
décision dans l'entreprise et je
donnerai enfants vous prendrai ensuite
la parole monsieur denis terrien dont
notre président a déjà vanté les mérites
qui est président de l'institut français
des administrateurs
donc nous comptons sur vous comme vous
l'avez compris pour nous inspirer dans
notre travail à venir de parlementaires
merci merci madame la sénatrice merci
madame la présidente de nous de m'avoir
invité à cette table ronde
merci madame la députée zimmermann de
nous avoir situé cette fête historique
jeu je voulais d'abord vous dire que
l'association que je préside a été créé
en 2011 dans une idée bien précise
c'était celle d'accompagner le
déploiement de la loi copé zimmermann
nous avions deux axes de tram de travail
c'était d'une part utiliser le réseau
des experts comptables au plus près des
entreprises
expert comptable et commissaire aux
comptes puisque mon association regroupe
également les femmes commissaires aux
comptes
accompagner la loi copé zimmermann au
plus près de toutes les entreprises et
également former les femmes expert
comptable qui souhaitaient rejoindre un
conseil d'administration s'appuyer sur
ces femmes qui dans la profession serait
motivée pour évidemment servir d'exemple
dans la sphère qui est la nôtre la
sphère financière pendant quatre ans de
2014 à 2017
nous avons étudié le déploiement de
cette phase on va dire de
sensibilisation de la loi copé
zimmermann
avant d'arriver à 2017 année
d'application ce que nous avons constaté
on l'a déjà dit je vais pas répéter tout
ce qui a été dit qu'est ce qu'on
constate en 2017 connais pas tout à fait
dans les dans les clous que seules les
entreprises qui sont très médiatisées
sont dans les clous et que vous avez
vous prendre la côte nous avons étudié
pendant quatre ans les 625 entreprises
que nous avions ciblé sur la côte des
trois compartiments
on avait rajouté l'alternext on était
dans le quota uniquement sur les
entreprises très médiatisé et plus on
descend des évidemment plus en néon
perdre et les entreprises pour arriver à
peine à 28% l'année d'après nous avons
décidé d'aller plus loin et d'essayer
d'europe de repérer toutes les
entreprises françaises qui rentrait
dans les dents les chiffres de chiffre
d'affaires effectif qui étaient donc
concernés par la loi copé zimmermann
nous avons décidé que nous ne voulions
pas arrêter notre étude aux entreprises
cotées puisque le cac40 le sbf 120 on
voyait bien qu'ils y étaient presque et
qu'ils y seraient nous voulions
réellement connaître
nous nous sommes heurtés à deux choses
la première des choses c'est
l'information dès que vous arrivez dès
que vous voulez connaître l'ensemble des
entreprises soumises à la loi des plus
petites
c'est d'abord le problème de la collecte
d'informations ensuite un autre frein
nous est apparu dans ces entreprises ou
descendez dans la taille des entreprises
en france
si vous n'avez plus de conseils
d'administration vous n'avez plus de
conseils de surveillance vous n'avez
plus de s à vous avez le grand succès de
la ss et dans la sas depuis maintenant
dix à quinze ans les comités la
gouvernance est organisé comme les
statuts le souhaite il y a une liberté
statutaire concernant la gouvernance des
sas est un grand succès de la ss
nous avons donc vu de limites nous avons
dû nous avons vu se réduire
considérablement plus en étant la loi
on a vu se réduire considérablement la
base et la difficulté de collecter
l'information
alors nous avons dit nous femmes experts
compteur
comme vous l'avez dit mesdames des
réseaux notre association qui donc c'est
vraiment construite pour accompagner le
déploiement de cette loi évidemment nous
avons dit s'il ya bien des personnes qui
vont être en première ligne pour pousser
dans les entreprises ce sont les femmes
experts comptables j'ajoute comme mes
collègues que les hommes sont adhérents
aussi de l'association quand ils ont
envie de pousser les idées que nous
développons à partir de là on s'est dit
il ya un problème de connaissance et y
ait un problème
2 comme je les dis de de l'absence
d'organes de gouvernance dans beaucoup
d'entreprises françaises donc descendre
les seuils
pourquoi faire une loi et des sanctions
est entre les deux que se passe-t-il
il y a un problème de déclarations ayant
un problème de contrôle il n'y a pas de
loi qui puisse prévoir un cadre et des
sanctions sans qu'au milieu il n'y ait
pas de trous dans la raquette et le trou
dans la raquette c'est la déclaration
nous sommes un pays la france qui est un
pays déclaratif et nous devons déclarer
et nous devons contrôler et déjà le fait
de déclarer est une mesure vertueuse
parce que qui dit déclaré dit qu'on a
une obligation tout le match comme ça en
france la fiscalité le social on déclare
on a donc des conseils qui n'hésitent
pas à vous rappeler qu'il faut déclarer
et que s'il faut déclarer que si vous
déclarez pas il ya des sanctions
il y actuellement une méconnaissance de
la loi des seuils
il y à une absence de déclaration et il
n'y a pas de contrôle
donc la loi oui les comex l'écho dire
les sanctions de plus en plus sévères
mais il faut combler le trou dans la
raquette
alors moi je me suis j'ai deux
propositions à faire en ce qui concerne
la déclaration et le contrôle en ce qui
concerne la déclaration j'ai réfléchi en
bonne professionnelle sur le terrain je
me suis dit bon encore une autre
obligation déclarative et puis je
regarde et je vois l'index égalité des
salaires tiens en voilà donc un exemple
de déclaration qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on fait un index
enfin on remplit tout ce qu'il faut pour
avoir un index on l'envoie on le met sur
le site internet de l'entreprise
l'entreprise on le publie
on est obligé de le publier et on l'en
l'inspecteur du travail parce que
publiée sur le site internet ça ne
suffirait pas donc je me suis dit il ya
un autre exemple qui m'est venue ça a
été celui de la déclaration des
bénéficiaires effectifs dans la loi de
contre le blanchiment
voilà une loi qui depuis trois ou quatre
ans impose à toutes les entreprises de
déclarer
quelles sont leurs bénéficiaires
effectifs pour dans le cadre de la lutte
pour le blanchiment
c'est à dire qu'on est même allé
chercher à l'intérieur de la de
l'actionnariat
les personnes qui sont en situation
d'être un bénéficiaire effectif de
l'entreprise quel que soit son statut a
priori officiers le juridique est ce
qu'il est en fonction de critères un
bénéficiaire effectif
la loi sur le blanchiment le registre
des bénéficiaires effectifs alors je me
suis posé la question j'ai dit mais qui
donc s'occupe en france du registre du
commerce et des sociétés
eh bien ce sont les greffes des
tribunaux de commerce
je me suis d'ailleurs c'est peut-être
moins le sujet aujourd'hui mais je me
suis aussi demandé mais un jour il va
peut-être falloir aussi se poser la
question des associations des syndicats
professionnels des organisations
diverses et je me suis dit il ya bien le
registre national des associations qui
sont tenus par les préfectures
donc nous avons l'arsenal j'ai donc
proposé que de manière simple et peu
coûteuse pour les entreprises nous ayons
une obligation de déclarer auprès des
greffes de tribunaux de commerce par le
gie infogreffe en ligne chaque année au
moment où on dépose les comptes et le
rapport de gestion et le peu le tout les
obligations qu'ont les entreprises de
chaque année déposé
le procès-verbal d'affectation des
résultats sont le rapport de gouvernance
rapport de gestion est également le les
comptes annuels
je rappelle entre parenthèses que toute
nomination d'administrateurs est
enregistrée obligatoire non bref donc
l'information est lié il faut que chaque
année de manière simple et peu coûteuse
et peu coûteuse
j'insiste parce que pour l'origine des
bénéficiaires effectifs
ça a été un drame ça a été très dur pour
cette entreprise que l'entreprise puisse
déclarer
premièrement comment est organisé sa
gouvernance
comex codir organes de jeu qu'est ce que
balla parce que ça peut être dans une
sas a peut être extrêmement souple c'est
la liberté statutaire de l'organisation
de la gouvernance très bien on définit
qu'est ce que ces caisses la gauche
qu'est ce que la gouvernance comme on la
définit les bénéficiaires effectifs en
matière de blanchiment bâle ont défini
et on dit qu'on est organisé votre
gouvernance
voilà et puis vous déclarez l'organe de
gouvernance que vous avez et vous
déclarez en femme et vous déclarez
hommes-femmes s'il ya des choses qu'on a
eu l'habitude de faire pendant des
années on a toujours déclaré par exemple
on avait une déclaration sur le suivi de
l'apprentissage en france où on a
toujours été amené à déclarer combien
comment se compose et l'apprentissage
entre les femmes et des hommes dont
franchement là aujourd'hui en un sujet
qui est tout simple c'est de se dire à
quel moment on déclare qu'on est
organise la gouvernance et convainque se
compose et et ensuite nous allons parler
de contrôle et bien le contrôle il peut
être à deux niveaux le contrôle il peut
être dans les entreprises dotées d'un
commissaire aux comptes
ça peut être une obligation du
commissaire aux comptes que de contrôler
et pour cela ben c'est tout simple il
faut que l'inde le la la conel
formation soit dans le rapport de
gestion si l'information concernant la
parité
concernant l'organe de gouvernance
concernant la parité du l'obligation ou
non est ce qu'on est dans le cadre de la
loi ou non à partir du moment où c'est
une obligation qui est dans le rapport
de gestion le commissaire aux comptes au
titre de ces vérifications va forcément
devoir inclure ça dans sa mission et le
cercle vertueux parce que quand il ya
des sanctions et que les gens sont là
pour dire attention il ya des sanctions
vous n'êtes pas dans les clous on a mis
plus vous avez déclaré si vous déclarez
pas vous risquez ça bien le but c'est de
ne jamais arriver à la sanction parce
que la sanction est grave
aujourd'hui les sanctions sont
extrêmement graves et je suis très
soucieuse de savoir qu'aujourd'hui les
délibérations d'un conseil
d'administration qui mêle constituer son
nul et que beaucoup trop de personnes ne
le savent pas après tout ce qui a été
tout ce qui a été dit forcément je ne
vais pas répéter je vais dire que nous
notre travail de conseil
c'est d'assurer au niveau du tissu
français que ces règles qui ont été
posées par madame zimmermann par
monsieur copé ruisselle dans le tissu
français de la plume jusque dans la
petite entreprise parce que je pense que
c'est vous l'avez dit madame
aujourd'hui on le voit avec les
entreprises à mission le rôle de
l'entreprise et est vraiment à tout
de toute manière atout de taille de
s'assurer de certain équilibre en dehors
des limites de l'entreprise
et d'affirmer son rôle dans la société
je pense que j'ai terminé et j'ai été
très concrètes surtout en vue c'était
très bien vraiment
merci et ça je pense que ça sera le
gérer le vraiment le gérer le point de
bascule de l'application de la loi
là c'est imparable merci beaucoup
j'ai toujours dit que les noms mais
c'est vous savez pas les agnès bricard
françoise et elles m'ont aidé et vous
savez même temps comment ces des femmes
exceptionnelles
apparemment pour merci je m'adonne en
mai mais sa passe est vrai que nous
avons nous avons tu étais un vide
et là dessus je suis très heureuse très
heureuse que voilà moi je moi je le
préconise et et on me disait mais il
faut toujours se replacer en 2011
j'irai qu'il fallait y aller
progressivement et depuis 10 ans je et
si vous voulez tant qu'on était dans la
majorité bon je pouvais l'imposer voilà
après il ya eu d'autres priorités
malheureusement et là je vous remercie
beaucoup et ça il faut que ça fasse date
mais mais c'est important aussi de dire
forme d'art wet reconnu publié les
implantations des changes au gré des
faits doivent être accessibles et je
peux en dire que vous avez un nombre de
deux
d'universitaires nombre comme l'a dit
madame que nous avons entendu tout à
l'heure de personnes qui ont un mal fou
à obtenir les informations sinon donc
comment voulez vous qu'une loi soit
appliquée si personne ne sait et si
personne ne regarde
et si même celui qui veut regarder ne
trouve pas mes d'ailleurs ce que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure c'est que
autant tout ce qui est impactée par la
loi copé zimmermann gérer il ya ce
contrôle grâce à un floriane de saint
pierre entre autres mets et puis il ya
eu également monsieur le pechoux qui m'a
beaucoup aidé alors bénévolement à
récolter des récolter des informations
et ben moi même je suivais mais je crois
vraiment que aujourd'hui il faut l'encré
parce que voilà c'est ça a été géré une
loi qui acquit à laquelle l'ancien
système et aujourd'hui il faut l'encré
et juridiques sont les premiers il faut
voilà il faut donc créer cet index
c'est un la gouverne de la parité
dans la gouvernance française tout est
fait il faut à assortir sa de quelques
critères de définition de ce qu'est la
gouvernance parce que il ne faut pas
s'arrêter au comex codir puisque on a
beaucoup de structures différentes
il faut pas il faut aller sur les
associations il faut aller aussi dans le
milieu associatif
il ya de très belles très grande
association qui mérite aussi qu'on se
pose la question on a les registres et
voilà ce qu'il faut faire entre l'aide
merci infiniment nous allons donner la
parole à note le seul homme de notre
table ronde
mais voilà pas des moindres est comme ça
en plus sauf unis on finira par vous
monsieur merci d'avoir été patient mais
je pense qu'en effet pendant cette table
ronde était très riche et importante
donc voila nous nous écoutons et
n'hésitez pas à prendre le temps qu'il
vous faudra merci de votre accueil et
merci à toutes des témoignages je suis
aligné avec à peu près tout ce qui a été
partagée dont je représente ici
l'ifa l'institut français des
administrateurs notre souhait c'est de
promouvoir une gouvernance responsable
créatrice de valeur durable en
respectant le bien commun donc tous
sommes la plus grande association en
france d'administratrice administrateurs
on a plus de 4000 membres et tous les
mois c'est à peu près 500 personnes qui
travaillent dans nos clubs et commission
pour réfléchir sur la gouvernance alors
quelques donc l'ifas est engagée d'une
manière très déterminée sur ce sujet 50
% de notre conseil d'administration et
féminin tout à l'heure on parlait de la
prochaine présidente de michelin mais
sachez que nous avons à notre conseil
d'administration si angeles poveda cayla
président d'une haute société du cac 40
legrand et en plus celles étrangères
voilà donc angeles fait partie de notre
conseil d'administration
quand j'ai été élu il ya deux ans la
première décision que j'ai prise ces
deux j'avais demandé ça même avoir mon
émission de changer les statuts pour
pouvoir nommer une co présidente pas au
world co président et nous avons nommé
une que présidente en l'occurrence
ghislaine d'yèvre qui est secrétaire
général de la bnp
deux autres éléments aussi j'ai aussi
nommer une déléguée générale de lifar
karine dognin sauze kit est donc délégué
général infâme
si jamais on regarde nos comités on va
revenir là dessus
notre comité de nomination est présidé
par une femme et plus de 50% du bureau
aide est aussi féminin et enfin j'ai
institué une règle c'est pour tout les
clubs et commission nous en avant à peu
près 15 tous les clubs et commissions
doivent être coprésidé par un homme et
une femme
donc là le sully face est engagée d'une
manière très volontaire dans l'égalité
alors nous prenons notre part dans les
défis qui ont été lancé parce
qu'effectivement il ya eu énormément de
progrès et d'ailleurs on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'éthique aborde chaque année
lifar présente les résultats de cette
parité avec tout atteindre autre élément
avec éthique abordé c'est le baromètre
ifa et icade board et donc nous
investissons beaucoup pour continuer de
le faire
donc oui il y à la loi a fait pour les
sociétés qui sont
visible comme le bouvier et moi pour les
sociétés qui sont moins visibles et là
dessus donc on a deux actions le premier
ça a été de créer un club des hautes et
y présidée par fanny letier donc là
aussi on regarde comment et la
gouvernance au niveau des deux pays et
en a créé on a d'ailleurs créé des
recommandations sur améliorer la
gouvernance des outils qui inclut ceux
non seulement à voir par exemple des
administrateurs administratrices
indépendantes mais aussi s'appliquer
cette parité
deuxièmement nous travaillons aussi pour
aider les hôtes y pour lequel des fois
c'est moins facile d'avoir des
administratrices ou administrateurs où
elles n'ont pas les moyens de se payer
un chasseur de têtes c'est que nous
avons aussi une bourse mandat donc voici
l'action que nous avons pris pour les
équipes car c'est là où aujourd'hui le
combat et la deuxième action
c'est pour la nomination dans les
comités spécialisés
parce que oui s'il y a beaucoup de fins
plus de femmes au niveau du conseil
d'administration les comités spécialisés
sont encore très féminin donc là nous
avons donné l'exemple en se l'appliquer
à nous-mêmes et ceci vient beaucoup pas
la formation et donc il y as besoin de
former les administratrices et
administrateur et en est heureux
d'annoncer cette année qu'on va avoir
formé plus de 1000 administratrice
administrateurs dans nos programmes de
formation
donc on avait un historique avec
sciences po on en a ouvert un autre avec
hec pour les oatei familiale en à odense
ya aussi à dompter avec les hôtes et y
est d'ailleurs la manière dont on
regarde ça c'est que chaque instance
chaque type d'entreprise à une
gouvernance un petit peu spécifiques et
ir même on lançait les recommandations
sur la gouvernance des start up à la
licorne et on fait ça avec le ministre
cdh rico
parce que comment on passe d'une start
up à la licorne là aussi il y a des
spécificités de gouvernance
voilà alors le sujet donc sur les
limites dont on a parlé là dessus l'ifa
s'engage très activement
premièrement montre en exemple
deuxièmement dans toutes nos axes de
formation
aujourd'hui la question est est ce qu'il
y a besoin d'élargir sa au niveau des
comex et que dire donc là je vous
réponde avec une autre casquette que
j'ai aussi dirigeants et présidents
d'entreprises j'ai été le premier
personnes à nommer une femme comme
présidente d'une institution financière
en france en l'occurrence cofidis et
même sur la boîte technologique dans
lequel j'exerce à rollmann numéro 2 et
féminin et je vais recruter une personne
féminine aussi pour continuer d'élargir
en france dont j'ai eu un travail très
travaillent effectivement d'affirmations
pour m'assurer qu'il y ait cette équité
au sein de l'équipe dirigeante
en revanche m une loi de pourcentage mac
y est
et je vais vous dire pourquoi j'ai eu la
chance de travailler dans un univers
très féminin dans l'univers de la mode
ou dans l'univers des crèches dans
l'univers de la mode et des crèches dans
la mode c'est à peu près 80% des
employés sont féminins et donc on voit
très bien au comité de direction
on regroupe 60 à 80% des personnes sont
féminins dans l'édition on dans les
crèches dans les crèches 95 % des
employés sont féminines et donc aux
coureurs comité de direction c'est que
des femmes
donc là on aurait le problème inverse
donc lyle que que je vraiment que je
soutiens en tant que dirigeant n'est pas
de mettre un pourcentage 40%
mais que ce soit un ratio par rapport un
ratio par rapport aux employés dans
l'entreprise
voilà dans le secteur est d'ailleurs on
peut voir que les la mesure des
personnes dans le comex
les quatre ce sont les sept entreprises
du cac 40 les plus en avance 4 sont un
secteur de la beauté et du luxe lvmh
hermès qui régnait le real parce qu'il y
a des talents dans cette entreprise
qui grimpe donc ma la recommandation
n'est pas une loi absolue parce que
j'entends aujourd'hui que ces iem est
beaucoup plus relative à aux employés
qu'il y avait au cadre et qu'il ya et ça
aussi c'est mesurer le nombre de fans de
société et mesurer le nombre cadres
dirigeants et mesurée émettons important
noah en relativité par rapport à ça
alors je sais que c'est un peu plus
délicat c'est plus facile de mettre 1 4
absolu mais ça répondra à la dynamique
des entreprises parce que c'est ça qu'il
faut faire
deuxièmement aussi il y à une question
de temps parce que pour former quelqu'un
pour rentrer au comex ou que dire il
faut un certain nombre d'années est donc
là aussi dans cette période d'adaptation
je suis tout à fait sur le conflit au x
blade et il faut que le dg de 10 en
début d'année voile voici les actions
que je vais mener pour avancer sur sur
cette diversité et qu'après ils viennent
sur expliqué le conseil d'administration
leur voilà ce que j'ai menées donc ça
c'est vraiment les deux recommandations
que nous avons c'est si jamais il y a un
pourcentage qui me qui est mis en
liaison avec les employés ou le type
d'employés et deuxièmement qu'il y ait
un temps quand même car on ne on ne
tourne on ne forme pas une patron de la
r&d de peugeot ou patrons des usines de
peu de renault en trois ans il faut pas
qu'il faut plusieurs années pour arriver
à ça là est donc là dessus sur cette
formation on assiste beaucoup voilà les
recommandations que j'avais à vous faire
merci merci infiniment on était en train
de saisir quand même temps les quotas
vous savez en cantons pour en politique
on a été obligé de venir vers la parité
on n'avait pas du tout apprécié d'être
comparé à des quotas laitiers mais
c'était obligatoire et si nous ne
l'avions pas fait nous serions encore
entrés très minoritaire un très forte
minorité nous le sommes nous ne sommes
pas encore à la maladie et à la parité
au au sénat mais ça ça progresse et
malheureusement c'est compliqué mais
souvent on n'a pas trop le choix que de
fixer un seuil pour que ça motive aussi
les gens de 2,2 le fait mais ce qui est
très drôle c'est qu'aujourd'hui en effet
les hommes qui s'inquiètent de se dire
mais nous serons sûrement minoritaires
maintenant dans certains domaines et
donc à falloir nous aussi qu'on
progresse
et comme me disait valéry douchez de
notre directrice
ça ferait du bien aux hommes nés dans
les crèches voilà donc je voudrais dire
je je je roulais sa parole dans les
irrésistibles échangés non non je
voudrais simplement dire quand même pour
revenir un petit peu sur l'histoire on a
toujours refusé de parler de quotas il y
avait d'ailleurs été refusée en termes
de politique bien sûr oui c'est vrai
qu'on l'a répété à nombreuses reprises
mais c'est vrai que le terme de parité
avait été choisi parce qu'effectivement
c'était beaucoup plus valorisant c'était
une notion d'équité aussi et c'était
extrêmement important et ça rejoint
aussi ce que vous dites sur ces
questions d' équilibre nécessaire
pardon je referme l'apparent marie-jo
alors sur le temps ça je crois que tout
le monde s'accorde à dire
qu'effectivement on ne peut pas imposer
en un temps très court
et d'ailleurs la loi les lois la loi sur
sur les conseils d'administration
c'était six ans et je voulais rappeler
aussi tout à l'heure par rapport aux
statistiques
quand on ne compte en 2014 najat vallaud
belkacem des 100 à 250
elle a donné un délai
six ans de nouveau donc si vous voulez
je crois que sur le temps tout le monde
s'accorde là dessus alors sur les
secteurs je crois que là aussi au niveau
du medef il ya un questionnement et un
questionnement réel
et je crois que je voulais c'est
l'intelligence comme à mon avis du
gouvernement du délai du législateur qui
va résoudre le problème je crois parce
que ici vous avez raison de l'évoquer
parce que c'est tout à fait différent
comme je le disais tout à l'heure moi ma
préoccupation depuis depuis que j'ai je
me suis mise à travailler sur cette
question donc ça fait ya un certain
temps en 2012 en 2002 notamment
ça a été l'application de la loi sur
l'égalité professionnelle sur l'ensemble
de l'entreprise
donc je crois si vous voulez que si
aujourd'hui on se pose la question des
colibris comex c'est tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas respecté la loi je
l'unission entre autres voilà on va être
très clair là dessus et donc on peut pas
rattraper en avec un texte mais il y a
un mix et a fait à c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué hier à la ministre
je crois qu'on peut il faut pas imposer
sur l'éco dirait des collectes
il faut aujourd'hui tapé du poing sur la
table et dire il faut appliquer les lois
sur l'égalité professionnelle
sur l'ensemble de l'entreprise est
automatiquement avec une incitation sur
les colis relais comex y aura davantage
de femmes mais là excusez moi enfin bon
c'est quand même c'est quand même dur
d'entendre d'être obligé de dire ça en
donc je suis moi vraiment tu essaies
c'est vraiment l'aspect - qui m'a
toujours pas rôdés et ça contient
tarauder parce que c'est sympathique de
vouloir légiférer sur les collyres et
des comics mais non d'une pipe
pourquoi il n'y a pas de femmes dans les
colis à des collègues pourquoi on parle
de fissurer le plafond de verre et non
pas de les exploser parce qu'on n'a pas
respecté la loi sur l'égalité
professionnelle qui était excellente
en 2001 voilà donc maintenant je crois
que un moment donné l'aller le
législateur que j'ai été table sur la
table edit bon stop c'est très bien tout
ce que tout ce qu'on propose pour le
contrôle de la loi pour tout ça bravo
merci et aujourd'hui on est dans dans la
dans le moment où on peut le faire mais
mes stops de simplement légiférer sur la
partie de ce qu'on appelle la direction
aujourd'hui
appliquons la loi génisson sur le gérer
sur l'égalité professionnelle et excusez
moi je vais je vais iconoclaste ans dans
l'entente dans ce système mais qu'en
2017 on a commencé très mal avec les
ordonnances
on a tous des âges est donc aujourd'hui
c'était très sympathique
sauf qu'aujourd'hui il faut revenir à
l'essentiel qui est l'égalité
professionnelle et ensuite on sera
respectée sinon on ne sera pas respectée
voilà madame dati mon jeu je pense que
c'est très important parce qu'il s'agit
de la responsabilité des entreprises et
jacquouille à cette attente je suis
entièrement d'accord que c'est pas c'est
la face visible de l'iceberg en fait les
comex 1 et donc c'est vrai que c'est
important de je pense on attend celle de
légiférer en même temps c'est important
que à la base justement que ce soit en
matière de recrutement en matière
d'application de la loi donc l'index
pénicaud a été un outil important mais
il est maintenant disons à revoir
peut-être pour halle pour aller plus
loin moi ce que j'aurais juste dire pour
répondre en effet je sais bien qu'à la
question des secteurs en disant mais oui
mais c'est impossible d'avoir 50 % de
comité de direction dans un secteur où
il y a que 20 % 2
deux femmes je pense que si je sais bien
que c'est un questionnement qui est
légitime
en même temps je pense qu'on peut donner
un peu plus de temps mais mais mais
réellement si on si on s'enferme dans en
disant qu'on va avoir une une loi pour
les secteurs où il ya déjà 50 de femmes
opus
et pour ce qu'il en est en moi c'est un
piège absolument terrible qui va
ralentir complètement les les progrès
dans ce secteur là bas madame je ne
faisais pas pour le secteur voit qu'il
ya 50% de femmes offrir des secteurs
dans lequel il ya plus de 50% de femmes
oui donc c'était les met de l'équité par
rapport aux personnes dans les secteurs
dans lequel yann 80% de femmes équilibré
un petit peu dans le sens bien sur la
période 80% tom équilibré mais attention
ce n'est pas que de divisions d'accord
mais je crois comprendre que le medef
s'interroge sur ces questions là
justement des secteurs dans lesquels il
y à une minorité de femmes de se dire
comment elles vont pouvoir accéder dans
excusez moi ça faisait mal compris mais
c'est vrai que ça faisait référence
je sais à cette interrogation et je
pense que pour nous qui sommes dans les
entreprises où il ya moins de femmes ja
je dirais que si on va on arrive à
légiférer que nous puissions au mois
avoir les mêmes la même aspiration et le
même espoir que les autres secteurs
[Musique]